uh we've known this guy for this is
coming up on
almost 10 years when he was back on our
podcast days
rocking an old 1980 an 85
bears ditka jersey uh sweater
back in the day um enjoyed his work
obviously on new girl my kids
loved spider-man into the spider-verse
and
next up however is something that i'm
gonna have to put the kids away for
uh when uh when it streams on netflix
starting up on this friday um
it is called a hoops and animated comedy
phil lord and chris miller have been on
this show
speaking of uh spider-verse um
and uh the lego movie um they are the uh
eps and this is a funny show that jake
johnson is starring in as the
high school coach at the center of it
all and jake johnson back here on the
rich eisen show how are you jake
i'm great rich how are you nice to meet
you better for talking to you
uh how's everything in your life
everybody hopefully happy healthy
safe yeah we're doing fine and i'm going
to tell you what o.g
you missed out on i don't think it's
mitch trubisky who needs to win
and be honest nick foles does not need
to win but there is an og
yes a chicago uniform who needs it and
that's
mack khalil mack
okay he he is a dominant player i'm so
happy we haven't we're spending a lot of
money
and he was single-handedly going to be
the guy who took our defense and
reminded us what the mid 80s were like
in chicago yep
and i'm a big fan i'm glad we have them
this is the year the bears defense is
supposed to
just dominate fools again well i think
you need it is the whole
thing i i don't know what the hell
happened to the offense last year
whatsoever i mean what did you think of
tho when when you heard foles got
acquired
jake what did you think you know i'll
tell you i i
really wanted cam um
i don't i don't and this is not against
nick foles because dick foles is a
winner no
but i don't understand what is going on
with decision makers in the nfl
cam newton is a stud
he is a franchise quarterback who had
been playing
injured and playing his heart out
if you're in chicago and you have a
chance for
cam newton
for not a lot of money on a one-year
deal
cam newton in chicago
with that defense i don't understand why
we didn't do it i was really hoping to
hear
that there was some injury report that
we weren't getting
and then when the patriots got them and
everybody's checking
everything's checking out fine rich i
gotta tell you i'm a little confused
what's going on
brother we were sitting here pounding
the table for this very idea back in
april
back in may um obviously you know
the falls trade happened um and that was
the end of that
but i don't get it that one i don't
i don't understand it and yeah i'll tell
you another thing i don't get
is this idea that if you don't know
the playbook we're trying to do like
nick
it knows the system right so i get it
that helps
don't you want the best players
available jake i hear you
the whole thing is here's what i think
it is i think it is
that if they did go to cam that would
have been
this is like for the lack of it lack of
better phrase a half measure which is
something that
you know it's difficult to call when you
acquire a super bowl mvp as foles
is one of the few humans to walk around
planet earth with that on his resume
but i think if you go cam then you're
essentially saying
that's it for mitchell that at least
this is uh and in case of
20 2019 trubisky break glass
right where i think that's the only
reasonable explanation i could come up
with
let me put it in a in a way that i could
try to relate to this rich
yes and in my industry in our industry
could you imagine auditioning for a role
like to
act in something okay and the person the
studio puts
next to you to audition for that role
they're thinking
he's probably jake will probably beat
him because he's not that good
or should they put the best available to
see if i can
rise to the occasion
and i'm not once mitch to risky i like
him still yes
he's in court he's not the guy i wanted
drafted
exclusively because i had never heard of
him
so so you're basically saying um in this
equation
um that uh nick foles is not the meryl
streep
that we're talking about they're saying
we don't want pam newton he's because we
think he might be better than mr
right i'm confused of what i'm watching
that's i i think that
literally is what it is and we had matt
nagy on a few weeks ago and he said that
the one thing that he wants to
trubisky needs to work on is not get
down
when the mistake gets made and not to
get too high when something's so great
but not get down when don't get too hard
on themselves when the
mistakes get made and after the
conversation i'm like
um well getting nick foles isn't that
something that's gonna
trigger that whole negativity and second
thought process i
i don't know i just i just hope for the
best for you here
and i guess do you want to if trubisky
starts do you want him to work out or do
you have such a lack of confidence in
him that you just
want to see what foles has got going on
no way i first of all i'm not against
mitch travis
bears fan uh you know i like him i think
he's a good
quarterback i think what happened last
year which was
you know because he he gets hit hard um
mitch trubisky is at his best when he
runs for like 40 yards
when mitch trubisky is running around
throwing the ball and just playing
football
he's a pretty good quarterback and he
might actually be really good
last year i don't know if he got hurt
early like his shoulder injury
and i don't know if they told him stop
running because we can't win with the
backup uh
chase daniel but you gotta let it rip a
little bit
jake here on this show you know and
again i just jake johnson here and we'll
talk about hoops in a second
um on this show um you know
we would call what you just did with
talking about trubisky and hoping it
works out
uh you went higher register um and when
you go higher register in your voice
that indicates that you're not really
into that like hey you know what
you know like go you know when you go
when you go higher register
um it kind of undercuts the statement
that somebody's making i don't know if
you feel that way but i think you just
did that
here's where it is i'm not a huge
college football fan
okay right i i've never been into it
i've always been into pros yes
i saw deshaun watson playing uh the
national championship yes you did and
i haven't walked his season or his
career
wow was he good
he not only that his head coach who i
don't know much about
came out and said this guy is such a
leader
he's like the michael jordan of college
football that speaks that resonates with
a bears fan i'm a chicago sports fan i'd
imagine
it worked at that point i think we had
the number three pick and i was looking
at the mock drafts
and i said you know i think there's a
chance
the michael jordan of cal poly who i saw
with my own eyes
you were good so i started reading and i
thought
wow we might have watson as our
quarterback for 10 years
then rich the night of the draft we
trade up
three to two yes you do well i'm not
gonna lie i didn't know who patrick
mahones was and i didn't want him
so i was wrong but i knew who watson was
when we traded up i thought i'm a man in
my 40s
i think i'm buying a watson drink
when they said the name mitchell
trubisky yeah
i thought it was a prank
yeah roger roger goodell isn't involved
in punk
i don't think he usually does that sort
of stuff no he isn't punk people
mitchell and then i googled him and i
read
he was a backup at north carolina rich
i'm gonna be honest i didn't realize
north carolina
had a football team
[Laughter]
we've got jake johnson here on the rich
eisen show i've got about four minutes
left
uh and a conversation so i definitely
want to talk about your show hoops which
is
we've got rob riggle coming on on on
thursday
and it is a funny um
not safe for kids um animated series in
which you play a high school coach
who hopes that we're turning around your
terrible team gets you to the big time
who do you channel as the coach here you
know
kind of all the coaches growing up um
that i watched on tv who were so loud
and abusive and ridiculous and
culturally we celebrated these guys i
think there's been a
shift that these guys are now being seen
as just being poorly behaved
but there was a period of time where
they were seen as you know heroes
and what this show is is a super funny
super
vulgar super loud animated show for
adults and i can't emphasize that enough
the first minute there's probably 10
f-bombs
so if you are an individual who is
easily
you know offended hoops is not for you
but this is one of those shows where
there's no lesson to it there's no heart
to it
there's no messaging it's we got a bunch
of really funny comedians
rob riggle being one of them natasha
alexario ron funches nick schwartz and
the
list goes on and we just let everybody
rest
yeah i mean when the most family
friendly is schwartz and you know what
you got going on right here so
and there there's not a moment of
sweetness in your show it is
vulgarity on top of vulgarity for the
sake of it
and you know i personally grew up in a
house where
loud jokes were always celebrated and so
this reminds me
of just people trying to be funny for
the sake of being funny and i hope
people enjoy it
well i mean that's going to be starting
streaming on netflix uh on
on this friday and my kids would be
upset if i didn't ask is there another
spider-man into the spider-verse coming
with you and
for the kids to be feasting i know that
they have started
they're working on it i know phil and
chris are always pushing and they've
been talking ideas
peter b parker has not gotten the call
yet
he's sitting on the sidelines eating
pizza hoping that somehow
the bears uh trade for deshaun
jake i hate to tell you man um uh that's
just not gonna happen
uh sadly yeah
maybe in another dimension right maybe
maybe in another dimension uh always
enjoy the chats jake do you still have
that uh sweater
that uh 85 bear sweater did it still fit
uh well i mean during quarantine i bet
it's a little tight in the middle
great chatting with you jake you take
care of yourself and let's do this again
real soon hopefully in person next time
okay
my friend right back at you that's uh
jake johnson at mr jake johnson on
instagram check him out oh man is there
one more
oh yeah there's one last still from
hoops that we haven't gotten to and it's
an outrage
i don't know what's this this is
supposed to be me
i i don't get it i don't have a soul
patch
my eyes don't look like that i mean rich
maybe you should they
i don't know did they did they get they
did
did they use a photograph of jim gray
instead of me
wilford brimley rest in peace no this is
wilford brimley from uh
cause i'm i i'm i'm a fairly long right
now i mean
you're at the brimly line by the way
absolutely rest in peace wilfred i mean
that happens that's right i know that's
right
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here